[Music]
[Applause]
all right the consequences of Joe
Biden's extreme weakness on the world
stage are growing by the hour tonight we
told you earlier about the French
president macron in China this week
meeting with President XI and the
president of Brazil announcing he'll be
inviting president XI to his country
when the two meet on Friday but Joe well
he's taken a trip to Ireland this week
uh to walk in the footsteps of his
ancestors and plans to visit castles
while he's there maybe build a sand
castle also anyway how does the trip to
Ireland help America stand up to our
adversaries our very own peter Ducey
asked that very question take a look
you got this Ireland trip next week
The Dramatics I was applied to trip to
Ireland helped counter China
or end the war in Ukraine so let me just
say a couple of things the president is
certainly looking forward to taking this
trip to Northern Ireland and also the UK
where he'll be heading out on Tuesday we
certainly will have more to share on
this trip uh coming in the upcoming days
as my colleague just said on Monday but
I I also want to lay out here the
important kind of the important history
between us and Ireland right
all right here now with more he is the
host of the number one show on weekends
right here on the Fox News Channel life
liberty and Levin nationally syndicated
radio host
our audience before you get started
you all had a message for Mark what's
the message
got a message from Mark
[Applause]
there you go great one I want to ask you
this thank you very very much yeah
talking about China there are alliance
with Putin the alliance with Iran now
the Saudis have chosen sides they're now
going with China and Russia and Iran and
you see the world disintegrating and
your President Joe is going over to
visit castles in Ireland
uh your thoughts
you've lost Brazil
Brazil now is with China that's in our
own hemisphere we have used to have
something called the Monroe Doctrine
let me read you a list Sean
invasion of foreigners severe economic
troubles division of the Empire Empire
stretch too thin
government corruption and political
instability loss of Traditional Values
weakening of the legions the military
that is what combined to destroy the
Roman Empire
the Roman Empire last A Thousand Years
we're not even close to A Thousand Years
every one of those seven or eight issues
is something we are confronting today
and Rome fell in 476 CE of its own
weight we have something going on in
this country that we've never had before
we have a Marxist Revolution that is
destroying us from within while the
enemy gathers abroad
and there is an access of powers against
us right now it's China Russia Iran and
North Korea this is no joke
China hasn't built the biggest Navy on
the face of the Earth
military islands in the South China Sea
over 27 bases of different kinds in our
hemisphere
a a deep water naval base in Samaya
where my great uncle fought on
Guadalcanal
you have a China with a base on the
western coast of Africa facing us killer
satellites nuclear missiles you think
they're building all that to defeat
Taiwan
they're building all that to defeat us
they're not going to be satisfied with
Taiwan
they're in battles now with the
Philippines and Japan even Vietnam
Australia's being threatened
unless you're Helen Keller you can't see
this and hear what's going on here
this is a big damn deal and let me tell
you something that viewers of this
audience and others may not want to hear
we need to prepare for war against China
I don't mean go to war I don't mean
initiate a war but they are preparing
for war we are completely unprepared as
a nation psychologically we are
completely unprepared economically and
immigration wise and securing our border
our military is not prepared in the
sense that they're pushing this woke
ideology our military budgets do not
reflect the threats that we are facing
in the world around us I want to say it
again so the back bench is regurgitated
we must prepare for war against China
not because we want war not because
we're going to cause War but because
they want war they've only communicated
it ten thousand different ways whether
it's violating our airspace navigable
Waters threatening our ships threatening
our country threatening our people what
else can they do short of attacking
they're not going to be satisfied with
Taiwan
this is a big damn deal and we don't
have the military brass and the pentacon
to deal with this the secretary defense
or Secretary of State we've never been
so weak that's what she sees he sees
what I see he sees what the rest of the
damn world sees this is no joke when you
have the French this guy what is he
Vichy France this guy stabs us to the
back mccrone Lafayette remember
Lafayette he helped us during the
Revolutionary War he defied the the
monarchy he joined Washington he led the
Battle of Brandywine he got wounded he
was with us the French helped us at the
end of the war here's France where we
sent GIS to Europe
to liberate France and many of them died
and look what this bastard does to us
the president of France he goes over to
China
at the height of tensions
stabs Us in the back
says he will not support us
he's provoking the Chinese to act talks
about autonomy you can stick your
autonomy France as far as I'm concerned
Joe Biden Joe Biden gets elected
putatively anyway he's Mr diplomacy
tells the world we're back Mr globalist
Mr experience let me tell you something
he's dragging this country into
depression he's dragging this country
into war not because of what the
isolationists say but because of the
opposite we're not acting like a
confident strong country and so people
are disrespecting us he keeps calling
she we don't know what he's telling him
but I can imagine what he's telling what
do they keep saying we don't want
conflict we want competition stop
calling G because you're demonstrating
to him how damn weak you are
We the People deserve a better leader
than this and a better government than
this but this is what we put up with
it's absolutely unbelievable that's it
I'm done
yeah yeah
I think that reaction tells it all the
great one Mark Levin thank you coming up
next from typical Biden fashion the
president gave a very bizarre response
when asked what his plans are for 2024.
we're going to play that tape Kaylee
mcinany Jimmy falia they will join us
next as we continue
wow
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else